[dramatic music]
- ALL RIGHT, WE'RE BACK,
AND THIS IS IT.
THE STAGE IS SET.
NATHAN HAS 90 SECONDS
TO FREE HIMSELF
FROM THOSE CUFFS
AND HIT THAT RED BUTTON
TO HIS RIGHT.
THE BUTTON IS A KILL SWITCH.
IT IS THE ONLY THING
THAT CAN STOP
THE PROGRAMMED MOTION
OF THE ROBOT
FROM TAKING OFF NATHAN'S PANTS
IN FRONT OF THESE KIDS.
AND NOW HE WILL
DELIVER THE LINE
GIVEN TO HIM
BY JUDGE FILOSA.
- SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN HERE,
AND IF IT DOES,
SO WHAT?
- AND WITH THAT,
HE HAS ESTABLISHED
WILLFUL INTENT.
SO IF HE
EXPOSES HIMSELF TONIGHT,
IN THE EYES OF THE LAW,
IT WILL NOT BE CONSIDERED
AN ACCIDENT.
- READY!
- GO!
- AND WE
ARE UNDERWAY NOW.
HMM, STRUGGLING.
LOOKED AS THOUGH HE--
HE PULLED A PICK
STRAIGHT FROM HIS HAIR.
NATHAN WORKING
ON THOSE HANDCUFFS.
WE ARE
80 SECONDS AWAY
FROM A LIFETIME
OF SCORN
FOR NATHAN.
[tense music]
NOW THE ROBOT
GOING TO THAT--
THAT FLY.
THE FLY IS DOWN.
AND WHILE
HE'S WORKING
ON THE HANDCUFFS,
THE ROBOT
CONTINUES TO WORK
ON THE PANTS.
♪
APPEARS AS THOUGH
HE'S TAUNTING.
NO, HE'S GOING
FOR THAT LOOP.
NOW HAS
THE BUTTON UNDONE.
♪
AND THE KIDS
LAUGHING ALONG
WITH THE ROBOT'S ANTICS.
[robot whirring]
NATHAN STRUGGLING
WITH THAT PICK.
HE DROPPED THE PICK.
♪
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S CAUGHT
ON HIS CLOTHING,
AND NOW HE'S TRYING
TO RETRIEVE IT,
AND HE'S GOT IT.
GOT IT WITH HIS--
WHAT A CLOSE CALL,
AS HE RETRIEVES THE PICK
WITH HIS TONGUE.
HAD THAT FALLEN
TO THE GROUND,
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ALL OVER.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE
THOSE LOOPS
ON THE HIP.
THIS IS GETTING
TIGHT HERE.
THE ROBOT NOW HAS
BOTH PANT LEGS DOWN,
IS ABOUT TO SECURE
THE LOOP
ON THE UNDERPANTS,
AND NATHAN'S STILL WORKING
ON THOSE CUFFS.
WE ARE JUST
20 SECONDS AWAY.
NATHAN WORKING
THOSE HANDCUFFS.
AND NOW IT LOOKS AS THOUGH,
WITH THE PANTS DOWN,
THE ROBOT GOING
FOR THAT UNDERWEAR LOOP.
WE ARE NOW AT TEN SECONDS
AND COUNTING.
♪
WE HAVE JUST
A COUPLE SECONDS LEFT.
OH, NO, WE ARE SEEING
PUBIC HAIR.
[buzzer]
BUT HE HAS ESCAPED.
NATHAN FIELDER
HAS MANAGED TO ESCAPE
AND SAVE HIMSELF
FROM A LIFETIME OF SHAME.
THERE'S THE REPLAY.
THE MOMENT WHERE HE WAS ABLE
TO PICK THE CUFFS,
HIT THE BUTTON
JUST IN TIME.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE RELIEF
ON HIS FACE.
[triumphant music]
WELL, THERE YOU SEE IT.
HE TOOK ON GREAT RISK,
AND NOW THIS,
HIS REWARD.
CONGRATULATIONS
FROM THE JUDGE AND OFFICER.
- GOOD JOB.
- THANK YOU.
- UM, SO THE ROBOT
PULLED HIS PANTS DOWN.
BUT HE WON.
[giggles]
SO--
- IT WAS REALLY FUNNY.
I REALLY WANTED HIS PANTS
TO FALL DOWN
'CAUSE IT'S HILARIOUS.
- I WOULD HAVE BEEN
SORT OF OFFENDED
IF IT--IF HIS UNDERWEAR
FELL DOWN,
BUT NOT THAT MUCH.
- HE PRESSED THE BUTTON,
AND THEN IT DIDN'T FALL DOWN.
I WAS LIKE, "YES!"
I WAS LIKE, "HALLELUJAH."
♪
- OKAY, BEFORE YOU GUYS--
BEFORE YOU GUYS LEAVE,
REMEMBER TO ALWAYS TAKE
BIG RISKS
AND BELIEVE IN YOURSELF
AND FOLLOW YOUR DREAMS,
JUST LIKE I DID.
I DRE--WELL, YEAH, I DID.
IT WAS--
IT WAS A DREAM OF--
[all laughing,
chattering at once]
YOU KIND OF TALKED
OVER MY SPEECH.